estamos en el museo nacional de
antropología en mexico mirando a lo que
quizás sea su objeto más famoso el
calendario azteca también conocido como
la piedra del sol se ha convertido en el
emblema de la cultura mexicana tiene una
forma circular como si fuera un sol que
emana rayos pero si lo miramos de cerca
en realidad nos vamos a dar cuenta que
se trata de un objeto increíblemente
sofisticado esta piedra originalmente
estaba pintada en lo cual pues nos
habría ayudado mucho a distinguir los
motivos que estamos viendo no estaba
empotrada en la pared más bien estaba
colocada de manera horizontal sobre el
suelo y no estaba terminada vamos a
comenzar por el centro
aquí se ve una cara medio tétrica con
los ojos muy sumidos y una boca ancha a
cada uno de sus lados cuelgan lo que
parecieran ser ornamentos para las
orejas lleva orejeras y dentro de esa
boca abierta hay una lengua que
sobresale esa lengua en realidad es un
cuchillo de sacrificios antropomorfa las
orejeras serán adornos que utilizaban la
élite
si miramos a los lados encontraremos que
tiene garras y esas garras se están
sosteniendo algo que probablemente son
corazones humanos ha habido varias
interpretaciones sobre quién era en
realidad este individuo la mayoría de
las personas lo identifican con el dios
del sol
tonatiuh que es la palabra náhuatl para
el dios del sol
nagua que es la lengua que hablaban los
aztecas quienes pertenecían a un grupo
étnico llamado enaguas lo que se
registra aquí en esta imagen en el
centro es más lo que se registra en todo
el disco en general es como los aztecas
visualizaban el origen del cursos la
piedra se refiere a uno de los
principales mitos aztecas la creación de
las diferentes épocas o como ellos
mismos las llaman y los soles lo que
estamos viendo aquí es un registro una
historia cataclísmica de épocas
anteriores y también la época actual la
época actual pues es considerada como
como el quinto sol sin embargo el nombre
del quinto sol la quinta era es cuatro
movimiento de hecho eso es lo que vemos
con los cuatro
los que rodean la figura central ese
signo que se forma es el símbolo de
ollin que en agua que significa
movimiento también vemos esos cuatro
puntos que rodean la figura central que
nos dan el nombre de nahui ollin cuatro
movimiento que es el título del quinto
sol o la quinta época que estamos
viviendo en nuestros momentos dentro de
esos rectángulos que significan audio
línea cuatro movimiento vemos los
nombres de los cuatro soles anteriores
a ver si partimos de la parte superior
derecha y le damos vuelta conforme al
contrario de las manecillas del reloj
las cuatro eras son cuatro jaguar cuatro
viento cuatro tlaloc y cuatro
chalchiuhtlicue la primera era se acaba
con los jaguares todo es devorado por
los jaguares la segunda era se termina
con fuertes vientos la tercera era se
acaba con con esta lluvia de fuego y
bueno pues la cuarta era se acaba con
inundaciones de agua distinto sol
profetiza que este mundo actual en el
que vivimos
va a terminar con terremotos la ciudad
donde estamos y de dónde proviene la
piedra la capital azteca está rodeada de
volcanes y de una línea de falla los
terremotos han sido espantosos y lo que
esta piedra está profetizando es cómo va
a terminar nuestro mundo actual con esa
cara en el centro hay una idea clara de
sacrificio existe dentro de la mitología
azteca el concepto de que esta era en la
cual estamos viviendo ha sido formada
por dos dioses que se ponen de acuerdo
para sacrificarse ellos mismos se
realiza la creación del sol gracias al
sacrificio que hacen los dioses pero en
un principio el sol era estático por eso
es que se requiere del sacrificio de
otro dios para poner al sol en
movimiento debido a que los dioses han
muerto de manera voluntaria nosotros
debemos alimentarlos con ofrendas
sacrificios de animales o perforaciones
de nuestro propio cuerpo brindando
nuestra sangre o sacrificios humanos
aquí tenemos 20 grifos o símbolos los 20
días del calendario azteca fuera de esta
franja de fechas calendárica
vemos los rayos del sol que irradia
hacia el exterior donde los más grandes
señalan los cuatro puntos cardinales
norte sur este y oeste su universo se
dividía en cuatro cuadrantes asociados
con estos cuatro puntos cardinales
tenochtitlán la ciudad capital del
imperio azteca estaba dividida también
en cuatro replicando ese diagrama
cosmológico si nos fijamos bien en la
banda exterior vamos a encontrar un par
de serpientes cuyas cabezas se juntan en
la parte interior central y de estas
cabezas surgen dos caras estas estas
serpientes se llaman serpientes de fuego
o cuco aquí están asociadas con el
tiempo con el calendario solar y en
algunas fuentes aparecen como portadoras
del sol a través del cielo es decir
ellas finalmente pues hacen que el
tiempo transcurra en cuanto a la forma
de fechar este monumento hay un par de
otros glifos aquí que me gustaría
señalar junto a la fecha 4 viento si
vamos hacia la izquierda nos encontramos
con la insignia real de modo que es una
segundo
pues nos hace fechar este monumento
durante el reinado de este monarca
azteca al otro lado de la insignia de
moctezuma segundo justo al lado de esa
cabeza de jaguar que marca la fecha 4
jaguar vemos un cuchillo de pedernal uno
de los cuchillos de sacrificio
junto a él vemos un punto sólo esto se
lee como la fecha 1 pedernal algunas
personas asocian esa fecha en particular
con el comienzo de la era del quinto sol
lo que tenemos aquí es un sentido de la
estructura y el orden del universo de
los aztecas es un objeto que es muy muy
conocido sin embargo la mayoría de las
personas no están conscientes de los
mensajes tan sofisticados que se
transmiten en el calendario azteca
bueno